[Musique]
Georg Elser Ervin von treskov Fabian von
schlabrendorf rudolp von gerschdorf et
Klaus von
Staufenberg un simple ouvrier et quatre
officiers aristocrates C hommes qui ont
refusé l'indiciible
C hommes d'honneur C hommes qui ont
voulu tuer
Hitler mais il ne le savaiit pas Hitler
était
protégé par la chance du
diable voici leur
histoire c'est joyeux et en chanson que
les troupes allemandes s'enfoncent dans
les plaines russes Hitler a emmené
l'Allemagne à la conquête du monde en
chantant il avait promis à ses hommes la
victoire il les a conduit
cur
l'ocalypse les champs de gloire sont
dans l'enfer de l'hiver russe et les
rêves fous d'Hitler se sont dispersé
dans des vents
glacés
Hitler est un imbécile et un
criminel nous devons mettre fin à cette
société il ne s'agit pas de dire la
vérité à il s'agit de le tuer et je suis
prêt à le faire n'y a-til pas un seul
officier dans le QG d'Hitler qui so cap
d'abattre cette
[Musique]
bête l'histoire avait voulu les oublier
mais quelques hommes de bonne volonté
quelquesuns de ses plus proches
officiers ont bien tenté d'abattre cette
bête depuis 1933 et la prise du pouvoir
par adolp Hitler plus de 30 tentatives
d'attentat pour le mettre hors de nuire
ont échoué car Hitler est bien
accompagné par la chance du
diable
Hitler nouveau chancelier du Reich s'est
octroyé le titre de fureur du peuple
allemand ce qui veut dire le guide il
s'est aussi proclamé chef suprême de
l'armée alors c'est à sa seule personne
qu'il fait jurer obéissance et fidélité
un terrible pacte lit désormais l'armée
et ses officiers à
Hitler nous nous sentions tous très mal
à l'aise parce que suivant la bonne
tradition militaire prussienne nous
avions désormais des
à l'égard d'un homme qui nous était
étranger et
détestable mais qui pouvait alors
deviner que Hitler profiterait de ce
serment pour nous enfermer dans des
ordres criminels car ils sont rares les
officiers à réprouver les méthodes naz
Hitler est à la fin des années 30 un
homme adulé par près de 90 % de ses
concitoyens les autres se taisent ou
sont en prison le tour de force d'un
magicien maléfique et c'est un pays tout
entier qui marche la croix gamé dans la
nuit
un homme a décidé d'agir si personne ne
peut stopper Hitler lui va oser il
s'appelle Johann Georg Elser ouvrier
qualifié et sympathisant communiste
Elser depuis 3 mois caché dans son
atelier prépare sa bombe les conditions
en Allemagne ne pourrait être modifié
que par l'élimination de la direction
actuelle par direction j'entendais les
supérieurs je veux dire Hitler ging et
gbbes j'avais la conviction que
l'élimination de ces trois hommes
permettrait à d'autres d'entrer au
gouvernement et veillerait à améliorer
les conditions sociales de la classe
ouvrière Elser n'est pas seul le général
Beck commandant en chef de l'état-major
de la vermart prépare un PCH avec
quelques officiers pour renverser ce
fureur qu'il méprise Hitler les a
contraints à la démission et après
l'Autriche et la tchéchoslovaquie il
lance ses troupes à l'assaut de la
Pologne le 1er septembre
1939 rien ne semble résister à l'armée
allemande et lesoua les bombardiers du
fureur expérimentent pour la première
fois des bombardements de terreur sur
Varsovie une véritable répétition
générale et les civils en sont les
premières victimes elsur à Munich
prépare son attentat il est le seul
désormais à pouvoir stopper Hitler
j'avais appris alors que la prochaine
réunion à laquelle assisterait la
direction se tiendrait les 8 et le 9
novembre à Munich à la Burg BR Keller je
quittais la petite salle où je
m'asseyais presque toujours à la même
place je passais par le vestiaire pour
déboucher dans la grande salle qui
n'était jamais fermé à clé et je me
cachais dans le kajibi situé près de la
sortie et dont la porte était masqué par
un grand paravant à la brasserie après
avoir dîné et s'être laissé enfermeré
Georg Elser va pendant 35 nuits préparer
sa cache dans la colonne près du pupitre
où Hitler doit tenir son discours
enfin le 6 novembre il peut installer sa
bombe dans la cavité le mécanisme est
réglé pour que l'engin explose le 8
novembre entre 21h15 et
21h30 dans la soirée du 8 novembre
Hitler embarque à bord de son avion
privé direction Munich il est un des
premiers hommes politiques à préférer
l'avion au train il peut ainsi prendre
la parole le même jour devant
différentes assemblées et dans cet avion
spécialement aménagé Hitler peut tout à
son aise travailler à la rédaction de
ces
discours il n'est pas encore 20h quand
le fureur fait son entrée dans la salle
comble de la burger
breller il monte à la tribune à 20h8
mais surprise son discours se termine à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
20h58
Hitler quitte la salle à
21h09 il semble pressé sombre et
préoccupé son pilote l'a prévenu qu'en
raison de la météo il doit rejoindre
Berlin par le
train pour une question d'horaire Hitler
donc raccourci son discours de moié ce
qui bouleverse le planning minutieux
deor
l'explosion a lieu à 21h20 comme prévu
8 personnes sont tuées et 63 sont
blessées Hitler lui est en route pour
Berlin dès 22h l'enquête permet de
découvrir les restes d'une bombe
artisanale les explosifs sont ceux
utilisés dans les carrières et le
mécanisme à retardement est celui d'une
pendule
toutes ces informations facilitent les
recherches et dans la journée du 9
novembre tout est résolu Georg Elser est
arrêté alors qu'il tente de passer la
frontière
[Musique]
suisse je me suis seulement livré à des
considérations quant aux moyens
permettant d'améliorer les conditions
sociales de la classe ouvrière et
d'éviter une guerre je n'y été incité
par personne je n'ai pas non plus été
influencé en quoi que ce soit dans ce
sens je n'ai jamais entendu de
conversation pareill ou similaire je
n'ai pas non plus entendu dire à la
radio de Moscou qu'il fallait renverser
le gouvernement allemand et le régime je
l'ai fait pour que plus aucun sang ne
soit versé j'ai agi seul je n'y étéis
incité par personne je n'ai jamais eu de
doute sur le bien fondé de mon
action pour le pouvoir allemand il est
impensable qu'un homme seul un homme du
peuple é été aussi près de réussir alors
dans la presse est exhibé la photo de
deux agents secret britannique qui
aurait tenté d'assassiner le fureur avec
l'aide
d'elsur une manipulation un faux avéré
Georg Elser le justicier solitaire est
envoyé en camp dans l'attente d'un
procès qui doit dénoncer le rôle des
anglais sans les caprices de la météo
Hitler aurait dû mourir l'attentat raté
est une véritable auèe pour le fureur il
peut dire qu'il est sous la protection
de la Divine Providence au lendemain des
funérailles des victimes de l'attentat
un rapport établi par le service des
renseignements des SS constate sa
tentative d'assassinat à Munich a
grandement renforcé la notion de
solidarité au sein de la population et
l'amour pour le fureur a
grandi Hitler est devenu un personnage
quasi
mythique malgré les réticences de son
étatmajor il est temps pour Hitler de
s'attaquer à l'ouest le 10 mA 40 il
lance ses troupes à l'assaut de la
Hollande de la Belgique et de la France
réputé la meilleure du monde l'armée
française est balayée en à peine 5
semaines l'audace du plan allemand et la
brutalité du Blitz creck ont raison des
troupes françaises trahies par un
commandement défaillant c'est la débacle
et le gouvernement français capitule
face à Hitler la défaite est consommée
avec la demande d'armistice du 20 juin
du maréchal Pétin pour adolp Hitler la
victoire est totale
le général ketel chef d'état-major
appelle désormais son fureur gruster
Felder aler tion le plus grand chef
militaire de tous les
temps Hitler a gagné son insensé Paris
il est le maître de la France et de
[Musique]
l'Europe pour le Conquérant il est temps
d'explorer son nouveau
domaine escorté de caméraman du service
de la propagande le dimanche 23 juin à
6h du matin Hitler entame une visite
éclair de Paris l'Arc de Triomphe
l'opéra La Madeleine la place de la
Concorde les Invalides et le tombeau de
Napoléon et enfin le cortège s'arrête à
l'esplanade du
Trocadero là Hitler pose pour les
caméras face à la Tour
e quelques mois plus tard des officiers
sous les ordres du f Marchal Leben
prévoit d'abattre Hitler lors d'une
parade sur les Champs-Élysées mais
Hitler n'est jamais revenu à
Paris une fois la guerre gagnée à
l'ouest Hitler se retourne vers l'Est il
est temps de s'attaquer à l'URSS
l'Empire judéoolchevique comme il
l'appelle le 22 juin 1941 aux premièr
lueur de l'aube débute l'opération
Barbarossa Hitler lance 125 divisions à
l'assaut de l'Union soviétique
précédé de milliers d'avions qui
écrasent en quelques heures les défenses
soviétiques tro immenses groupes
d'armées 5 millions d'hommes et 4300
chars enfonc l'Armée rouge et se rue au
nord vers Leningrad au centre vers
Moscou et au sud vers les plines àblé de
l'Ukraine et le pétrole du
caucas la plus grande invasion militaire
de tous les temps un véritable rouleau
compresseur lingrad est àorté de canon
Moscou 100 km et qui a fait
tomber rien ne semble pouvoir arrêter
Hitler sur ce qu'il nomme la conquête de
son espace
vital les pertes de l'Armée Rouge sont
colossales et les prisonniers se
comptent par millions peu vont survivre
à la barbarie nazie à l'état-major de la
Vermar le maréchal kettle a fait
distribuer une ordonnance à ses
officiers un véritable permis de tuer
pire même d'assassiner un texte
terrifiant atterri sur mon bureau il
portait la signature de Hitler et
ordonnait que tous les commissaires et
chefs politiques de l'Armée rouge qui
tomberaient entre nos mains soit livré
au services de sécurité afin d'être
éliminé ou abattu sur
place la guerre est monstrueuse mais
menée par Hitler elle le sera plus
encore chaque unité combattante de la
vermart doit être suivie d'un groupe de
SS les einat groupen chargé du
nettoyage arrestation
assassinat et exécution de masse tout
leur est autorisé en toute impunité et
en dehors de toute
juridiction leurs victimes les
communistes et surtout les populations
juives nous sommes des
soldats pas des assassins et tant que je
serai le chef du groupe armécentre il
n'y aura pas d'exécution d'agents
politiques ou de prisonniers que plus
jamais ne puisse se produire une chose
pareille
nous devons donc agir maintenant dans
des centaines d'années le monde se
souviendra encore de ce que nous avons
[Musique]
fait ils devaient se déshabiller creuser
leur fusse et attendre le coup de
grâce ils sont près d'un million de
victimes hommes femmes et enfants de ce
que l'histoire appellera la Choa par
[Musique]
bal
qui nous gouver ne sont à mes yeux
qu'une association de
malfaiteurs méthod criminelle pratiqué à
l'intérieur du comme dans les pays
conquis sont indignes d'un pays civilisé
il déshonore l'Allemagne tout en l'amant
à sa perte schlabor est l'adjoint du
colonelingeskov à l'étatmajor du front
de l'Est depuis 2 ansoneskov horrifié
par les crimes commis par les naz a
réuni autour de lui un groupe de fidèles
tous prêt à éliminer
Hitler les tentatives vont être
nombreuses mais toutes vont échouer la
sécurité s'est renforcée autour du
fureur ses déplacements et son agenda
sont désormais tenu secret schmun
l'officier d'état-major de hetitla
m'avait expliqué que tous les organes
vitaux de hetitla étaient protégés par
un gilet par bal efficace contre les
munitions de petit calibre de plus sa
casquette était doublée d'une plaque de
métal le monde retient son souffle quand
de juillet 42 à février 43 les armé
allemandes et soviétiques s'affrontent à
Stalingrad la bataille de Stalingrad est
la plus sanglante et la plus coûteuse en
vie humaine de toute l'histoire
militaire 6 mois de combat et 2 millions
de morts
elle est devenue un symbole et le fureur
a interdit à ses troupes tout mouvement
de
[Musique]
repli
encerclé submergé vaincu par les
Soviétiques le froid et la faim le 2
février 1943 plus de 90000 Allemands se
rendent dont 2500 officiers 24 généraux
et un maréchal frédrichon
Paulus Stalingrad met fin au myth de
l'invincibilité
[Musique]
d'Hitler après la défaite de r les
officiers sont nombreux à comprendre
qu'ils se sont laissés emporter par un
fou
furieux malgré leur serment de fidélité
certains pensent se retourner contre
leur maître le
[Musique]
fureur au quartier général à Smolensk le
colonel enin von treskov attend pour
agir nous avions appris que hetitla
envisageait de rendre visite au quartier
général de clou l'occasion était trop
belle selon moi les hauts chefs
militaires allemands n'étaient pas en
mesure de prendre l'initiative d'un coup
d'État ils accepteraient seulement de
suivre un ordre je décidais donc
d'assumer l'amorçage initial nous ne
pouvons absolument pas agir autrement si
nous voulons conserver encore un temps
soit peu l'estime de nous-même cela doit
se
[Musique]
faire
nous nous chargees nous-mêm des ultimes
préparatifs TR avait imaginé le
stratagème
suivant pour être sûr de l'effet nous
pres non pas un mais deux explosifs nous
en F un paquet dont la forme ressemblait
à deux flacons de
cognac puis il nous fallait
confectionner le paquet de manière à
pouvoir actionner le détonateur sans
détruire
[Musique]
emballage venu de Prusse orientale de
Condor identiques se préparent à
atterrir par mesure de protection
personne ne sait dans lequel se trouve
le fureur le convoi est accompagné d'une
escadriille de
[Musique]
chasse la matinée se passe entretien à
l'étatmajor puis le déjeuner est servi
aux messes des
[Musique]
officiers à table il fallut encore
supporter la bonne humeur de Hitler
heureux d'être au contact d'authentique
soldats le Fura avait fait venir son
cuisinier personnel et son médecin
chargé de goûter ses
plats Hitler se méfie de tous alors 12
gû à son
service garde personnel de laass
cuisinier et médecin le suivent à chaque
[Musique]
voyage penché sur son assiette les coues
sur la table ne se redressant que pour
avaler une
gorgée un spectacle
méprisable
[Musique]
il fallait agir vite le F all repartir
j'approcha donc le lieutenant colonel
voyager dans le même avion avec la plus
grande je lu demand voulait bien se
charger d'un colis pour
moi éc de bouteilles de Cognac voilà mon
[Musique]
prétexte wagen
bereit le colonel BR a accepté de se
charger du colis reste schabendorf à
amorcer la bombe
[Musique]
m
soulagé et avec la conscience du devoir
accompli treskov et schlabrendorf
regardent décoller le condor FW du
fureur vers ce qu'ils espèrent
l'enfer nousignorions pas que l'avion de
hitla comportait un dispositif spécial
de sûreté il se composait de plusieurs
cellules isolées la place de hitla était
blindée et conçu de manière à permettre
un saut immédiat en parachute à notre
avis la charge d'explosif devait suffire
à déchicter l'appareil tout entier et
même si cela ne se produisait pas il
arracherait au moins un morceau de
fuselage tellement important que l'avion
s'écraserait de toute façon au
sol accompagné de sa doublure et escorté
d'une escadriille de chasseurs l'avion
d'Hitler a mis le cap sur Berlin le
colonel brand ignore qu'il a embarqué
une bombe dans l'appareil de son
fureur
au quartier général de Smolensk la tente
près du poste de radio mire à rue
[Musique]
d'épreuve l'explosion devait avoir lieu
30 minutes plus tard selon nos calculs
l'avion devait se trouver près de Minsk
à ce momentl à chaque moment nous on
recevoir un message de l'un des
chasseurs d'escorte annonçant la perte
de l'appareil du Fura mais rien ne vint
enfin après 2h un message de routine en
provenance de Berlin annonce que le Fura
après une visite d'inspection sur le
front de l'Est est bien rentré en
Allemagne et a regagné son QG à l'heure
prévue il fallait nous rendre à
l'évidence si stupéfiant que cela puisse
paraître notre attentat avait échoué
Tresco et moi-même étions littéralement
assommés pour les deux conspirateurs il
est vital de récupérer le colis qui peut
les accuser schlabrendorf prend l'avion
pour Berlin avec deux véritables
bouteilles de Cognac et effectue l'ch en
expliquant au colonel Brant qu'il avait
méprise sur les bouteilles schlabrendorf
et tr vont trouver une autre occasion
pour leurs deux bombes une cérémonie
commémorative doit avoir lieu au Musée
de l'Armée pour les héros tomb au champ
de
bataille c'est une occasion à ne pas
rater oc F do assister en compag
de celui d'entre nous qui est résolu à
abattre doit être prêt à sacrifier sa
propre
vie à l'Arsenal le musé de l'armée
surunter Lindon Hitler est ACC par
Hering
V c'est mon AM le
colonel qui après avoir réfléchi un
instant m'a dit j'accepterai cette
mission
je l'accepterai pour le salut de la
[Musique]
patrie comme chaque année la cérémonie
débute par un concert dans la cour
d'honneur au programme la symphonie
numéro 7 de
Bruckner j'ai suggéré que le volontaire
qui accepterait l'exécution du projet
mettrait une bombe dans chaque manche de
son manteau et devrait ensuite après
avoir déclenché la mise à feu
s'approcher autant que possible du
Fura de cette manière l'homme qui
consentait au sacrifice de sa vie avait
au moins le maximum de chance de réussir
son
[Musique]
projet après le traditionnel concert
Hitler doit se rendre dans le musée
visiter une exposition de trophée et
d'armes pris au soviétique
c'est le colonel Gersdorf qui doit
servir de
guide pour pouvoir saluer du bras droit
Gersdorf place une seule bombe dans sa
manche gauche après avoir activé le
détonateur chimique il lui faut 15
minutes pour agir à ce moment Gersdorf
sera près d'Hitler et tout sera
accompli lorsque le cortège du Fura a
pénétré dans le hall d'exposition le
général schmun s'est approché de moi et
m'a prévenu que hitla consacrerait moins
de 5 minutes à l'inspection des trophées
ainsi donc il était matériellement
impossible de mener le projet à
exécution il me fallait au moins 10
[Musique]
minutes une visite de 5 minutes les 5
minutes les plus longues de la vie de
Gersdorf il a AC le sacrifice suprême se
faire sauter avec le
dictateur mais sans pratiquement jeter
un regard sur les trophées réunis le
fureur visite l'exposition au pas de
course en moins de 10
[Musique]
minutes
une visite éclaire c'est un Hitler
pressé comme s'il avait eu connaissance
d'un danger qui à la grande surprise de
sa suite quitte
[Musique]
l'exposition une visite bien trop rapide
pour le détonateur et Gersdorf n'a que
le temps de se précipiter dans les
toilettes pour désamorcer sa Mach
[Musique]
infernale Gersdorf a la vie sauve mais
l'attentat a échoué le deuxème échec en
moins de 8
[Musique]
jours Hitler ignorant le danger mortel
auquel il vient d'échapper salue les
troupes réunies en son honneur sur le
boulevard Hunter
Lindon dans les semaines qui suivent le
fureur va encore échapper à deux
tentatives
d'assassinat alors que l'Allemagne perd
la guerre sur le front de l'Est et qu'à
l'ouest s'annonce le débarquement allié
Hitler offre général Romel pour ses
exploits à la tête de l'Africa corps son
bâton de
maréchal Ervin Rommel est un des
personnages les plus populaires de la
propagande cinématographique nazie pour
les Allemands il est devenu une
véritable icône treskov et les autres
officiers de la verm qui s'opposent à
Hitler voudrait avoir à leur côté cet
homme que toute l'Allemagne adore et
pourrait suivre mais Romel comme
beaucoup d'autres officiers de s'estime
tenu par le serment qui le lit au
fureur durant l'hiver et le printemps 44
Hitler affecte Romel son officier
préféré au renforcement du M de
l'Atlantique
ouragefensif empêcher tout débarquement
sur les côtes
françaises un ouvrage vain car ils
étaient attendus et ils sont venus comme
l'avait prédit le maréchal Remel le
débarquement aura lieu ici en Normandie
et ce jour sera le jour le plus
long le 6 juin 1944 1213 bateaux de
guerre 736 navires de soutien 864
cargots et 4126 engins et péniches
débarquent 20000 véhicules et 156000
hommes sur les plages de
[Musique]
Normandie les Alliés ont mis pied en
France et rien ne pourra plus les
arrêter dans leur marche vers
Berlin Romel sait la bataille perdue et
désire même négocier une paix séparée
avec les alliés Montgomery l'anglais et
Eisener
l'Américain la résistance allemande et
les off conspirateur ont sondé Romel
mais il hésite il sait qu'un attentat se
prépare contre le
fureur il adhère peut-être à la
conspiration mais il pose ses exigences
Hitler doit être arrêté et
jugéel est résolument hostile à un
assassinat ce 17 juillet fidèle à son
habitude il est en tourné d'inspection
sur le front comme toujours l'adjudant
Daniel est au volant et le capitainem
Lang surveille le ciel les avions
anglo-américains s la Terreur il est
devenu presque impossible de circuler
mais rom N a cure lui que l'on surnomme
le général des grands chemins il est 17h
quand une patrouille de speedfire repère
le véhicule du maréchal Romel sur la
route de
vimouti les deux pilotes décident de
descendre pour une passe en
rasm le capitaine long a vu les de
avions qui fondent sur il est trop tard
pour trouver un abri
Romel ordonne à Daniel d'accélérer de
tenter de se
dégager rien à faire sur cette longue
ligne droite la voiture est déjà alignée
dans le collimateur des
[Musique]
chasseurs les mitrailleuses crépitent et
les balle frappe le
véhicule Daniel s'écroule
mort transpercé par une
balle la voiture hors de contrôle entame
une terrible embardé et verse dans un
fossé les chasseurs sont déjà remontés
vers les nuages Romel G sur l'herbe
normande grièvement blessé au crâne pour
Staufenberg trescov et la résistance
c'est une perte irréparable car ils se
trouvent privés de l'officier le plus
populaire et le plus compétent qu'ils
auraient pu gagner à leur cause
mais il est trop tard pour
renoncer puisque les généraux n'ont
maintenant abouti à
rien c'est au colonel de s'en
occuper en tant
qu'officier nous nous devons de sauver
l'Allemagne nous avons relevé ce défi
devant Dieu et notre conscience et cela
doit être fait parce que cet homme h là
est le mal
absolu ce jour du 20 juillet 1944 doit
être enfin le bon à Berlin le colonel
von Staufenberg et son aide de camp
Werner von efton embarque pour
ratsenburg la tanière du loup dans sa
sacoche Staufenberg emporte deux bombes
les mêmes bombes qui ont servi aux
attentats manqués de Smolensk et
Berlin colonel et compte de la vieille
noblesse prussienne von Staufenberg est
un de ces officiers de grande famille
qui a vu l'arrivée d'Hitler avec bonheur
brillant officier il sert sous les
ordres du maréchal Romel en Afrique du
Nord là en 1943 il est sévèrement blessé
et perd un œil sa main droite et deux
doigts de sa main
gauche sa longue convalessence se
transforme en une douloureuse remise en
question alors sa conscience et son
honneur lui imposent d'agir et il
rejoint la Résistance animée par
treskov depuis sa nomination à
l'étatmajor von Staufenberg est devenu
précieux à la résistance car il peut
régulièrement s'approcher
d'Hitler c'est lui qui fait parvenir au
fureur une version modifiée par le
général hbricht le colonel treskov et
lui-même des plans de l'opération
Valkyrie comme à son habitude Hitler va
les signer sans même les lire le piège
s'est refermé car ses plans modifiés
permettent à ceux qui les possède de
s'emparer de Berlin en cas de
trouble tuer Hitler l'opération Valkyrie
et mettre en place un nouveau
gouvernement le destin de l'Allemagne se
trouve sur les genoux du colonel
Staufenberg après 2h30 de vol
Staufenberg et fonfton se présentent aux
portes de la tanière du
[Musique]
loup devant eux se dresse le bunker du
fureur c'est derrière ces épais murs de
béton que se tiennent habituellement les
réunions
stratégiques et c'est là que Stenberg ve
frapp le béton renforceimpa le souffle
mortel causé par
l'explosion mais ce jour du fait de la
chaleur excessive Hitler de tenir la
réunion dans un des Bar de
[Musique]
bois
12h20 après avoir salué le fureur et sa
suite Staufenberg demande à prendre
congé pour se rafraîchir et changer de
chemise car la chaleur est
étouffante Hitler et sa suite se dirige
sans attendre vers la baraque car
mauvaise nouvelle pour stauenberg la
Réunion est avancé d'une demi-heure du
fait d'une visite dans l'après-midi de
Benito
[Musique]
Mussolini
j'avais demandé à pouvoir me rafraîchir
il faisait très chaud et mes blessures
de Guer bien apparentes faisaient qu'on
me posait peu de
questions mais dans cette cabane en bois
moins susceptible de renforcer
l'explosion que le bunker il semblait
plus prudent d'armer les deux engins
explosifs me tend la mette qui contenait
les bombes nous PLA les détonateurs sur
les charges je commencer à régler le
premier minuteur
soudain j'entends que quelqu'un
m'appelle à travers la
porte un appel pour moi du général fel
giib une charge est réglée plus le temps
pour la deuxième FFT l'emporte avec lui
une seule
bombe tant pis cela devrait
suffire
12h25 une vingtaine de haut dignitair et
généraux du Reich sont réunis dans la
pièce autour d'Adolf Hitler
[Musique]
le maréchal Kettel fait son rapport sur
la situation à l'Est Hitler attentif
suit sur les cartes les positions des
troupes 12h30 Staufenberg les rejoint il
salue son voisin le colonel
einbrand j'ai placé la sacoche sur le
sol sous la table
au pied du colonel
brand je lui ai dit que je la laisse là
quelques instants car j'ai un appel
urgent à donner à
Berlin personne
sétonne dans ce genre de réunion tous
les officiers sont très afférés et
beaucoup de coups de fil sont échangé
avec le
front est en place ce n'est plus qu'une
question de
temps j'ai trouvé un nouveau prétexte
pour sortir de la
pièce
gêné par la sacoche BR la déplace pour
l'appuyer de l'autre côté de la
[Musique]
table par ce geste anodin mais fatidique
le colonel BR éloigne la bombe
d'Hitler
[Musique]
12h40 Stenberg a quitté le
bâtiment il ne reste plus qu'à
attendre
[Musique]
j'ai senti le souffle sur mes
joues personne naurait pu survivre à une
telle
[Applaudissements]
explosion bar est parti
soufflerentrusion est to garde à cour
pour relever les blessés des
décombres Stenberg en est persuadé
Hitler est mort il vient de voir sa
dépouille sur un
[Musique]
brancard 12h47 stauenberg etften
remontent précipitamment dans leur
voiture ils doivent rejoindre Berlin au
plus vite mais le colonel von stauenberg
s'est trompé Hitler a survécu et souffre
seulement de quelques blessures
superficielles
les conjurés pensaient que leur complice
avaient coupé tous les moyens de
communication de la tanière du loup avec
Berlin mais dans leur précipitation
ceuxci ont oublié quelques relais des
informations contradictoires circulent
déjà 13h15 Klaus von Staufenberg d'école
de l'aérodrome en direction de Berlin
pour lui l'opération est un succès
Hitler est
mort à Berlin les ordres scellés de
l'opération Valkyrie ont été distribués
et le gouvernement provisoire constitué
sous la direction du général Beck à
Berlin le généralbricht et le colonel
kirnhim tous deux de la conjuration
attendent toujours une confirmation pour
lancer l'opération trois précieuses
heures sont perdues quand enfin
Staufenberg atterrit et leur confirme la
mort d'Adolf Hitler à 16h l'opération
Valkyrie est enfin lancée tous les
officiers mobilisés pour Valkyrie ont
reçu une enveloppe scellée dans
l'enveloppe des ordres brefs tous les
responsables ainsi que ging Borman
himler et gbbles doivent être arrêtés
immédiatement et leurs hommes désarmés
mais rien ne se passe comme prévu
soudain vers la fin d'après-midi résonne
dans tous les hautparleurs la voix du
fureur une petite clic d'officiers
ambitieux et sans scrupule a ourdi un
complot pour m'éliminer et exterminer
avec moi l'état-major de l'armée
[Musique]
allemande Hitler est bien vivant il a
revêtu un uniforme neuf pour accueillir
son ami Mussolini à la descente du train
Hitler confie à l'italien qu'il voit
dans sa survie la preuve irréfutable que
la Providence l'a choisi pour la
victoire
finale une sacoche déplacée un solide
pied de table des murs de bois qui ne
renvoient pas l'onde de choc et le temps
qui a manqué à Staufenberg pour armer sa
dernière bombe voilà les vraies raisons
du miracle alors qu'Hitler fait ses
adieux à Mussolini la répression bat
déjà son plein à Berlin et elle va être
implacable le major otimer qui commande
le régiment de la gardeang ses troupes
on lui avait demandé d'arrêter gobbles
il déclenche la chasse aux
insurg CEN est fini de l'opération
[Musique]
Valkyrie dans la soirée le général le
colonel von kirnhheim le lieutenant ven
et le colonel von Staufenberg sont
arrêtés et condamnés à mort sans procès
par le général
from pour sa survie from sans hésiter
trahit les conjurés il faut que les
témoins de sa collaboration
[Musique]
disparaissent vers minuit Stenberg et
ses amis sont
[Applaudissements]
exécutés
ils sont enterrés comme des soldats avec
leurs uniformes et médailles mais Hitler
furieux fera brûler leurs cadavres et
disperser les cendres dans un champ
despendag pour le compte ening von
treskov récemment promu général lui
l'âme la tête pensante de la résistance
à Hitler il est temps de faire son
testament pour protéger son épouse Erica
et ses enfants il a prévu de maquiller
son dans embuscade les partisans russes
sont nombreux dans les forêts et les
attaquent
fréquentent ce 21 juillet malgré la
brume matinale il fait beau à Ostrov sur
le front de l'Est c'est un homme
tranquille en paix avec sa conscience
qui salue son compagnon
d'armes celui qui parvient à garder ses
rêves d'enfants dans leur pureté à les
conserver sous sa poitrine nue et sans
défense celui qui malgré les Ries de ce
monde ose vivre comme il l'a rêvé dans
son enfance jusqu'au dernier jour oui
celui-là est un homme un homme dans son
entier désormais le monde entier va se
jeter sur nous et nous traîner dans la
boue je suis cependant intimement
persuadé et je n'ai jamais varié sur ce
point que nous avons bien fait d'agir
comme nous l'avons fait je tiens pour
l'ennemi mortel de l'Allemagne mais
aussi de l'humanité toute entière
lorsque dans quelques heures je me
présenterai devant le tribunal de Dieu
pour rendre compte de mes décisions et
de mes actes je crois que je pourrais le
faire en toute bonne conscience car je
produirai alors tout ce que j'ai
entrepris contre
etla de même que Dieu promit autrefois à
Abraham de ne pas détruire Sodome s'il y
avait seulement 10 justes dans la
ville de la même
manière j'espère que par respect pour
nous Dieu épargnera l'Allemagne j'uris
voulu que vous fussiez témoins de ma
mort je ne veux pas laisser en plus à
nos ennemis la satisfaction de
m'arracher à la
vie au
revoir nous nous reverrons dans un monde
[Musique]
meilleur
c'est en civil et après avoir été
dégradé et exclus de l'armée que les
conjurés
comparaissent pour tous les conjurés une
seule sentence la peine de mort le
tribunal est présidé par le juge R
frler quelques années de carrière ce
juge a déjà fait exécuter quelques
milliers d'Allemands opposants au régime
ils sont près de 200 à être envoyé à la
potence dont un maréchal 19 généraux 26
colonels deux ambassadeurs 7 diplomates
un ministre trois secrétaires d'État et
le chef de la police du
Reich Hitler l'avait exigé il voulait
les voir suspendu comme des quartiers de
viande à des CR de bouche
et pour que la mort soit lente à venir
et surtout douloureuse la corde de
chanvre est remplacée par l'acier d'une
corde à
piano et pour son plaisir extrême les
exécutions sont
filmées la mort n'est pas immédiate
l'agonie peut durer 20 minutes les
bobines sont portées chaque soir au QG
d'Hitler 500 reichmk la note de frais de
l'administration judiciaire à Berlin est
envoyée aux familles supplicié 125
reichmk sont prévus comme salaire au
[Musique]
bourreau ce jour du 18 octobre 1944 des
funérailles nationales sont offertes par
Hitler à son maréchal préféré Ervin
Rommel dans son discours d'adieu le
maréchal Ron dit son cœur appartenait au
fureur mais 4 jours plus tôt à midi de
généraux se présentent au domicile
Dervin Romel pour lui proposer un
sinistre marché pendant l'enquête suite
à l'opération Valkyrie le nom du
maréchal aurait été prononcé au cours
d'interrogatoire alors sur ordre du
fureur lui est proposé l'infamie d'un
procès où la mort avec les honneurs et
la garantie que rien n'arrivera à sa
famille Romel après avoir embrassé son
épouse et son fils Manfred monte dans la
voiture en compagnie des officiers 5
minutes plus tard il avale deux capsules
de sianure le héros des Allemands venait
officiellement de mourir d'une
[Musique]
embolie Hitler avait menacé le monde de
déchaîner la tempête mais aujourd'hui
c'est sur l'Allemagne que la tempête
crache ses dernières
flammes depuis l'attentat manqué à la
brasserie le 8 novembre 1939 Georg Elser
est un détenu particulier on le surnomme
le prisonnier secret ou le prisonnier
d'Hitler au camp de dacho ce matin du 9
avril 1945 sur un ordre venu du fureur
en personne de SS viennent abattre
elseur dans sa
[Musique]
cellule 20 jours plus tard les troupes
américaines libèrent le camp de
dascho 20 jours trop tard pour sauver
l'homme qui avait voulu tuer
Hitler le 21 avril 1945 les premiers
obus soviétiques atteignent
Berlin il va en tomber plus de 2
millions pour stopper les T34 les tanks
soviétiques des armes sont distribués
aux vieillards et aux
enfants les derniers soldats du fur
n'ont pas 12 ans
après les avoir salué et envoyé à la
mort Hitler retourne s'enterrer dans son
bnker il n'en sortira plus jamais
[Musique]
vivant la bataille de Berlin va durer
plus de 10 jours un combat acharné
désespéré rien ne peut plus résister au
soviétique les pertes sont terribles de
part et d'autre 2000 char soviétique
sont mis hors de combat et certains
d'entre eux par des soldats qui sont
encore des enfants
la ville ne veut pas se rendre au rus
mais il est trop tard le Reich qui
devait durer 1000 ans est en train de
s'effondrer à 1h du matin le dimanche 29
avril Eva brone la maîtresse d'Hitler
depuis 13 ans épouse son fureur au cours
d'une courte cérémoniebb Bor sont les
témoins d'état civil quelques coupes de
mousseux sont échangé avec le dernier
carré de fidèle Eva Brown rayonne elle
est maintenant fr
Hitler vers 3h du matin Hitler dicte à
sa secrétaire son testament privé TR
pages d'acyographi où il annonce
moi-même et mon épouse choisissons la
mort pour échapper à la honte de la
destitution ou de la capitulation notre
volonté est d'être brûlé immédiatement
sur
place lundi 30 avril le drapeau rouge
flotte sur le restag et Berlin à 15h30
Hitler rejoint sa chambre accompagné
d'Eva son épouse elle a choisi le poison
lui se dans la tempe à 15h50 les deux
cadavres sont transporté à l'extérieur
du bunker 200 L d'essence sont déversés
sur les corps et le feu y est mis
beaucoup avait voulu tuer Hitler mais il
s'est tué de sa propre main à la date
choisie et au cœur même de sa capitale
Berlin la guerre est une folie il faut
l'arrêter le personnage central est
Hitler il faut le tuer le monde doit
être délivré du plus grand criminel de
tous les temps nous devons l'abattre
comme un chien enragé qui menace
l'humanité toute
entière ils étaient guidés par leur
courage et leur honneur
treskov schlabrendorf
Gersdorf enberg
elsur tous ont voulu tuer Hitler tous
ont échoués si un seul de ces hommes
avaient réussi des millions de vies
humaines auraient été sauvées et la face
du monde
[Musique]
changé